okay all right for people joining this
livestream we are talking about curious
combination graphs and number theory for
version 12.1 yes it is a curious
combination it it's Charles that's what
it is
that's okay
that's good all right
I look at tag drew coughs so I haven't
seen this at all how have I seen this at
all how the tagging is being done we
mention it in brief in some meeting but
okay so I need the twelve one prototype
build like correct correct okay so in
that directed edge director that's new
could you go to the okay it's
interesting you have this problem to
where you need to magnify it with your
Swank new 8k display or something you've
avoided that but 4k but yes no actually
actually I don't need to magnify it I'm
doing that partly cuz of the live stream
I see
does this actually work with some if I
do a escape TDE
wow that's pretty Swank oops
tab goes there how the heck do you make
that work I think that's how these
template boxes work okay my Swiss bank
um let me report over script to this
spelling czars and I saw somebody else
could do that but um Havas Krypton under
script should be in our spelling
dictionary
um okay all right so now this what is a
tagged graph Charles are you gonna tell
me or am I going to just look look for
it well essentially edges have attack so
they're numbered here in this case is
that right yes so why not allow the
possibility in tagged graph of giving it
a second argument or something or maybe
it's a different argument that is I mean
that that labels I mean like it like for
example in this case so I don't
understand that first usage so the first
Ridge essentially does that
automatically for you by assigning an
index without one - right but it's just
like just like in in the case how do you
label and I mean usually if I say say
graph whether we've got some weird
crowd noise here something that seems
like somebody might be like rolling a
cigar or something no idea what these
things actually are I've no idea what
that even sounds like sorry let's let's
even um the okay so by the way does this
you know does this should absolutely
have a thing that says label of vertices
in the predictive interface don't you
agree
we got we getting an attached cell to
graphs that you're gonna have Florida
operations that you can do okay well and
a lot of things that you should be able
to do there is just that style you know
these resetting things okay but we could
probably quickly add add vertex labels
here couldn't we think so Charles yes I
can't talk to the developer of the
predictive interface so fine okay so I'm
trying to understand here what is a
I mean okay the core problem let me
explain before we get too entangled why
do we even care about this okay the
problem is this that if you're gonna
attach properties for instance or
annotations on two different edges you
need to be able to pinpoint them so
let's say that you have two parallel
edges you want one to be read and want
to be blue you need to be able to point
to one or the other to attach the
annotation in this case color mm-hmm in
our original design when we started to
support multi graphs we didn't we knew
about this problem but we didn't think
it would be significant it turned out it
has become significant
and this is a barrier to use so several
users have come back and said look I
can't really I can't get the edges I
can't set the property I need to set
what the annotation I need set and so
the solution to this is to uniquely tag
them so the problem you had previously
was you could have one arrow to one
arrow to right edges are the same
they're the same you couldn't tell them
apart
right and it would be slightly
unpredictable what it does when it
applies to all of them some of them
doesn't it now but wouldn't it be nice
in terms of the input if you could just
say graph and then you could say
something like one arrow to arrow and
then the tag just as an input thing
rather than having to go through all of
this and I'm not sure that's the right
one but something like that well the you
use arrow for everything so I mean we
could have that beat that the tag
meaning that if you have a I'm not sure
if that's right I'm just I'm just
raising that I think that it's always
convenient if there's a a very
syntactically straightforward way to
enter the thing even if that's not how
it stays right okay all right but so a
tag graph I don't quite understand this
I mean is there a version of graph that
has two arguments like this
yeah vertices and edges correct they all
do right but but the vertices are
usually derived from the edges if you
don't give them a I'm saying I could
grab vertices and edges and it's you
know that means that you can have
isolated edges with no answer isolated
vertices we'd know it I get it I
understand what bothers me here is that
it will be nice to have given that this
is all about tagging in a graph a
convenient way to specify the tags like
for example in this form here being able
to like make that an association with
the keys being the tags or something I
don't know why
of the targa by self it was that he was
automating one of the limitations on
user complain about because usually they
don't want to specify the tag we'd
expect that you'll automatically work
right so that was kind of the key idea
for sure we can add another constructor
like in this case we have intake indexed
a graph who does that you know where you
can specify an index where to start or
integer type thing so we can add you
know more additional constructor missing
index tag graph no this is crazy
no look you can't have tagged graph an
index tagged graph names that are almost
identical to utterly different things
right one of them this one is adding
tags to a graph right
buta adding tag no this one is not
adding tags this one is taking it and
unless what you do is to support the
form tag graph of graph and add tags to
it right which it does actually well and
then what's the difference between tag
grow of an index tag drop so they have
two different way to assign it a graph
indexed a graph actually tagged all edge
starting at index one where the tag have
actually resolve that ambiguity that you
can build you can give a graph with you
know edge fully tagged or partially
tagged but we resolve it automatically
for you again so you can specify the
graph with the list of edges right and
some of the edge may have some tags on
me not have tags yep right so what our
graph does is that it resolved that
automatically for you and assigned those
tags so
is ambiguous to cuff so that you have an
index which is unique for each edge
doesn't say it does that he's on in the
details it's actually okay with that
that's wrong you should put it up here
if the objective is to take a graph and
add tags put it in here okay it doesn't
say where does it say that I don't even
see it says by saying that I don't see
it saying that's the stakes a tariff
object I think that the graph needs bt
to be in the use K in the use box yes
doesn't even mention it anywhere so if I
take this you're saying now how do I
tell that it did anything there okay I
am totally confused here so so it is
this there are two workflow different
here we are trying to provide so that is
the case where most of the user until
version 12 now George in-ear aitikaf
like you type there 1 goes to 2 1 goes
to 2 and they are sign styling or to the
cuff and then they just want to have to
work yes so to make that work
automatically the best is to tag graph
to that edges when it says we to make
them unique but there is also a separate
workflow where you want to take a list
of edges or half and then just
automatically assign tag until ok listen
I do not believe this name I don't
believe in this name so this is doing
something very specific
this is this is trying to edge tag a
graph right it's trying to tag the edges
of a graph it's not like annotations
which are doing all kinds of other
tagging that's right um it has no
relation with the notation I know
has no relation I know I mean annotation
can be applied to an edge correct yes
but this is burning it in by really
labeling that edge with a tag right yes
I don't like the term tag graph because
what this is really doing is its edge
disambiguating graphs and and based on
what I've seen it do here what it's
doing is it's only doing that in this
case at least it's adding tags for every
unique edge right so if I were to do
this up here graph a goes to B have a
double edge there then I'd get that and
if I go down here and I say tag graph of
that then what I would expect as I will
get yeah a B 1 a B - right so ok so what
this is doing I mean I would have
thought that be much more useful
constructor you know that's more useful
thing to put first in the box is adds
tags to the edges of a graph to make
them unique right which it doesn't say
anywhere here am I making sense yes ok
it doesn't say it anywhere I'm not I'm
not missing it right doesn't say it
anywhere no but we see typically of
course photographs where we generate the
edge tags but that's not what it's
saying I mean if I read that if I look
up here that's what it's doing here it's
not saying you can take an existing
graph and re tag its edges right sure
yeah in this page we design for says
that workflow because ie think and I
because I think that that worker is not
the most important when people want it
so wait a second so the alternative
would be that graph itself could have an
option of some kind I mean you're
imagining that people just like people
can say planar graph or something
exactly where they give a graph that
happens to be planar okay so the the
after the fact at you you definitely
should put it in the box up here okay
okay um is this a standard nametag graph
is there a standard name for this
concept an edge tag object I know that
that is edge tagged but in principle
usually people don't give a specific
name to the cuff which have tags okay
knocking on a live stream is saying this
PhD thesis I adopted a graph tagging
system based on vertex vectors tags edge
has a tag that is represented by the
component the two vertices having common
what if they have the same I'm confused
by that I don't see how that
disambiguates um sandal on our live
stream is pointing out that in the
neural net framework one arrow true
arrow 3 is equivalent to one arrow two
and two arrow three but we've got a lot
of background noise here if something
clanking around is it possible to fix
that um okay comments on both of these
please comment on this for me that
syntax is not that important we can add
it but well I think we should do
something that is consistent with what's
done in neural nets and I don't know
whether we can we look at that please
sure
who's taking notes here I'm taking note
okay can we please get rid of the
background noise
could we please get rid of the
background noise I don't know what that
is but just you know we shouldn't need
that and we didn't have anybody assigned
to take notes other than Charles here
okay um okay well I'm not thrilled with
the word tagged okay now what what
operations so can we do all of our
operations on these tagged graphs yes
that's cool okay now what is an indexed
tagged goth just uses a different
tagging scheme there's a globally unique
you have a running index from you know
however many edges your heart whether
they're duplicates or not there you get
a unique tag stylist and I understand so
these are two boys there's just you
indexing schemes we have this thing that
it's important in some cases to for for
operations and programmatically makes it
a little bit easier if you have a
globally unique index to work on don't
we have something which is renamed
vertices to be start from one what
exactly is called index graph or index
graph forget which with which one is it
index of us which is a graph that
renames see what's bothering I mean
index graph is nicely ambiguous between
the noun and the verb here um index
tagged graph is it's very odd because it
says index a tagged graph is one way to
read it right which is sort of what it
does well
except it's indexing in a different
sense because it's not doing vertex
indexing is it it's just doing the edge
tag indexing that's correct okay let's
let's walk through this again for a
minute okay okay so we also need a term
like edge tags which is okay do you
really like the term tag for these
things
I think it's decent
spent I spent some we spent some time
early on in trying to come up with what
are the possible names yeah and nothing
really materialized okay
you sort of came back to tag repeatedly
it's like an index it's like yeah we got
index tag and they label is bad you know
label and ylabel is bad because label is
something that just hangs off it it's
not it's not integral to the thing
itself
exactly
you
um let's see various people on our live
stream is suggesting various things here
um Michael is saying say the edge E is 1
5 goes to 2 5 a 2 tag because the common
component is the second one okay
I called this theory typed typed graphs
I see yeah that's a the would okay
there's people pointing out various
analogies here um yeah
marker ID and tags suggests and ER he
said also generic though I mean what
this is is dealing with multi edges
right that's that's it's only life is
dealing with multi edges so true
statement yes so it's just so freaking
weird to have something which sounds
like it's a big important thing that is
relevant to any graph but it's only
relevant to graphs that have multi edges
yes
I mean I could argue that the graph
shouldn't exists because everything you
can do with multi graphs you can do with
weighted graphs I mean it's a particular
waiting and so you could argue that
multigraphs or not needed period I mean
it's you can use tag tag in a niche has
a storage has a notation you can use it
to a military bunch of things
it's depend of how you look at it well
are you in fact imagining because
essentially you can build a graph and
then you just use that tag you know
those edge because I mean the tag has a
storage and then you can retrieve that
information let me point out that this
doesn't do that right this tagged graph
is specifically not doing that because
it's labeling it's just yes is a
constructor to solve a problem you use a
kind of but I don't think it's right if
we want to okay look look if we're gonna
do this we could have vertex you know
you know v1 v2 and then if you really
want to do it this way then we need
something which is like a 1 e 2 and then
we need the tags t1 t2 etc etc etc which
probably need to go along with needs to
be more like t1 t2 arrow or the other
way around I'm not sure which see what
I'm saying this
that's why user cannot just put it
directly with an edge you know you can
just step on the high tech edge the
right edge and then you add a tag I'm
saying I'm saying if we have this
function right that is called a tagged
graph we have to be able to explain that
you really can put things in here not oh
you can get away with putting things in
here but this is intended for you to put
giant data structures in here see what
I'm saying yes so wait for someone to
specified or study independently on do
now I don't know this is the right form
for doing this
you know edge ones error I mean I think
this is probably a form you should
support
maybe you should also support the I mean
this list of things which are edged
directed edge of you know one to tag see
what I'm saying
I think this begins to look more
reasonable given the argument that
people will really store things in these
tags as opposed to storing them in the
annotations right right charles's yes
because annotations mostly do not
survive operations on graphs correct it
does actually that that in irritants of
kerchief as we call it at the time
okay well then in what sense but in a
tagged graph you really guarantee is
there a different guarantee for when it
survives why can't I just use
annotations you can hone to understand
why I mean but we need to uniquely
identify that with multi edges you've
got a sort of uniquely identify where
it's associated to oh I understand that
I understand but I'm saying that why
can't I wrap one edge with a green
annotation when I drew the red
annotation and I've got a way to
distinguish the edges well but you want
operation like if you do cycles and then
you get to edge out you need to know
that that edge is the first one instead
of second one what do you mean I mean if
I annotated one with red and one with
green I get out whichever which I can
return you to edge from you know one to
two but it doesn't tell you that
annotation okay so this is exactly what
I'm asking you right what I was trying
to understand is a tag is something
which was burnt into that edge it's part
of the edge right whereas an annotation
is something that might fall off right
but then you answered that in many
operations we are preserving annotations
when we can but some of the time we
can't or don't want to correct yes okay
so I mean the definition of a tag is
something which is really integral to
the graph it never falls off and I think
that's reasonable and I think that the
terms tag and annotations
seem sort of okay for expressing those
two different concepts Roger what do you
think yeah I think that it's reasonable
okay but then then it's important in
terms of documentation that we really
document like this form here and
whatever form we're going to have with
associations or something so that we
emphasize that people can actually put
tags in there right with a unique I mean
this should probably say unique integer
well no this is is doing something even
different right so this is saying that
what this should say is yields at a
graph in which each edge has a tag
associated with it right yes and that
tag simply you know indexes the edge
right as opposed to the globally indexed
tag graph tagged graph in which so in
this case Charles if I'm not mistaken
right um the in this case the tagging is
for every is the the index is for each
distinct edge right whereas in the other
one is for every edge in the graph
correct it's like okay so how are we
going to capture that idea so one of
them is that we've already got this
notion of an index graph it says they
had assess the notion of parallel edges
down there well you know in the notes
below to the illustrations two
paragraphs down new tags parallel edges
are integers starting at one existing in
mind but how do we capture that in a way
that anybody can remember what's going
on I mean so in general so I think the
illustrations exactly shows that idea
fine discern let's try and capture it in
the name of the function okay so this
function if this is tagged graph how do
we do we need to say edge tags graph can
you respond Charles I don't really like
I don't I don't think that we have you
know vertex start event I understand we
don't have that but the point is okay
what about when we have ports right when
when this thing I mean we don't have
that notion yet right around an edge
there are three ports and one of them is
this edge another is that edge another
is that edge right what's happening with
that you mean to support all yes yes yes
introducing the idea of ports no there's
nothing there right now I I know there's
nothing there right now I'm trying to
avoid the same mistake we made with
property right where where the thing has
you know this term tag is extremely
general and I would like to avoid you
know because I don't understand the
relationship between ports and what
you're calling tags here because there
every one of these edges right it's
going to have an additional index
associated with it that says what port
of that vertex it's coming out of right
yeah how is that going to relate to this
I personally I don't see any direct
relation with tagging but there is a
relation because here every look what's
happening is every independent Verta
every independent edge coming out of
that vertex has to have a unique things
but I mean most likely the way that
we're gonna do ports is to say that
well I I don't know how we're gonna do
ports you know I really wish we could
get rid of the background noise here
really wish we could you know set it up
so we don't have that um but in a case
that do we have any kind of proto design
for ports we know on that work question
don't wait nuts that's worth talking
about okay but have you looked at what
the neuron that framework does Charles
yes yes I mean for Sabich you know even
do to visit essentially will have a
vertex and we specified since similar to
a notice on you know no you will have
three port port 1 port 2 and then we'll
attach to them and essentially is
dependent operation if is the layout
algorithm then the layout will to the
appropriate in by matching the edge with
the port yes but I don't see that way I
don't see directly the relation between
the tag because the tag is attached to
the name as well as in edge is define
uniquely under 40 defined uniquely can I
understand your argument I'm just
concerned with all these names you know
by the time we have an index tagged
ported graph something is wrong right
because imagine that we might want to
take it off and do the same thing you're
doing with tagging here and saying burn
its ports in again what I'm saying yes
um ok well ok all right
why is ok so when we have an index graph
that is re-indexing the vertices right
yes I mean it's it live
it changes the the names I know I know I
know I know right so the question is how
do we capture the concept of see I just
don't get it if you say index tagged
graph it says if it isn't unpossible
what that means because index graph
somewhat cheetah Li means reindex the
graph basically right so can you guys
offer some suggestions
yeah I mean I mean personally I mean we
went down to that hood and in the design
we discussed about it myself I was
thinking about it define a month okay so
what other names have we thought about I
mean one was essentially flee between
you know tagged index instead of intact
a scarf was tagged in take stuff which
was one of the proposal we went down to
to a name I don't think that's right
because tagged index craft suggests that
it's whatever index graph is it's the
tagged version of that which is the
wrong thing what it really is is paren
index tag close paren graph yes or
something maybe like you saw just maybe
we need to be more specific so if we go
with actually saying is basically edge
in this case maybe that will help you
know because of the ambiguity yeah I
mean I think if we called it an edge tag
graph I kind of like that idea because I
think that it's if you see that any
piece of code it's sort of you have some
fighting chance of understanding what
that means I don't mind her at all yes
that's okay
all right so then but then that comes
around to everything do you see there on
the left on the names right tag no edge
tags works fine sure edge tagged graph
queue obviously has to be changed
oh my god what's the right version of
this so if this is an edge tagged graph
I mean I guess that is the least
incomprehensible of what index edge
tagged graph so that is using index
essentially as a verb yeah fine it's
okay with me it's okay with you guys
yeah yes okay let's move on the
wonderful world of annotations yeah so
you're gonna obsolete the properties to
stuff but carry it over right it's gonna
it's gonna rewrite itself in evaluation
to annotation right yes okay so this
annotation now agrees with every other
use of annotation for audio for this for
that for the other right well so far is
just graph and meysrit actually used
that a permutation in the constructor
through graph from what UNMISS this
region I'm wondering this vigil okay
butBut doesn't our annotation rules is
used by other things right yes that the
wrapper is not yet used by those other
things it will be used in some of the
text cases right okay it's a very motley
list of things that uses it audio
boundary mesh graft mesh region okay
what on earth is that and why okay
wouldn't have been my very first choice
of a example to use the mega mega mesh
okay
so let's just look at how this works so
you're saying annotation rules for
element 2 1 which we can't actually see
here right yes can't you give us a
simpler example here
sure but wanting to notice is that
actually a notation hole is the probably
dissemble no one will use but because in
principle is used for serialization of
those and mutation right
each constructor usually actually like
for CAF you actually use a mutation as
your helper or has a vertex tile but you
don't really white a notation all and
then these them I understand
fair enough
okay let's look at what annotate does
that should take knowing as what it's
also no no do not ever say something
like that come on why are you saying
that don't say that why would we say
that wait a minute it's just confusing
he was still tentative I mean I was just
going to divorce again you just remove
it remove that please remove that it's
just gonna confuse everybody okay I
understand what this is no sets the
annotation but it's not like this it's
always has a left-hand side doesn't it
for the yes but you can set it globally
all right but it's always of the form
object and then a rule you know quiero
value here basically right right yes
okay so this isn't correct up here right
because that doesn't show that it's
always of the form quiero value correct
it is always a reformed quiero value
isn't it yes okay then please document
it like that okay otherwise nobody's
gonna understand it okay
as or is it not true that sort of the
form chiara value well solve that come
back yes in general for graph and mesh
is always clear value the thing is you
know when we decide to generalize oh as
we've said that you generalize it for
audio and other stuff right for example
where you have something loud what loud
me loud doesn't go to true or false
right well don't
call it data I mean then call it
annotation or something here okay all
right okay this needs more work you're
gonna need to come back next time you
come back for goodness sake don't have
background noise it's driving me
absolutely up the wall go find a
different place to do this call from or
something okay there all right let's
let's
quick look here we're running out of
time when we've got another meeting we
have to do here um and Roger Wiccan
Anita I don't know exactly when we're
gonna fit this in maybe tomorrow um
we've got to go back and go over these
some more okay Kendra yeah
um and by the way is it possible to have
these be links next time to the actual
in 12.1 to the actual to the source no
not to the source to the built thing we
must have ability there won't be
anything built there futurist
you know we should make it so that in
the prototype build that stuff gets
built why not mmm then we probably
better start cleaning up some of this
this so much well so long as it has a
future ice strike why not why not build
it so long as it you know in other words
so long as we need some other marker
that prevents it from being built no no
no I'm saying I'm saying in the
prototype build yeah I get it I get it
but we've used hundreds of pages I mean
maybe even thousands but definitely
hundreds of pages that our future ice
there are work products that will you
know you've seen some of these best
Sanjay knew and then it gets to be it's
so what so what so you build it I mean
so who cares it's just a computer I mean
I mean it only gets built in the
prototype build it does not get built in
the main build obviously right yeah
don't we already have oh I see
we had expression tree in the trees
project that Tony is working on right
what's the relationship between an
expression graph an expression tree it
is I mean as far as I can
it's the same thing okay so why don't we
what actual ground for expression okay I
understand but I well okay and maybe
Tony that was I think that was part of
the design for the tree system okay I we
should look at this some more let's not
rush this okay
but but next time we look at this can we
make sure that Tony is available so that
we can tell us what the relationship is
to tree Gogh and so on fair oh my gosh
what is all this what is this stuff
it's a refresh of a number theory
functionality so the documentation or
they or the content mostly documentation
there's a few things that have gotten
updates like prime PI and prayin I've no
new state-of-the-art implementations
that's cool well how far do they go jaws
because the boundary of 10 to the 15 we
have in earlier version currently the
record isn't the record is known to 10
to the 30 so okay for which for prime of
Phi prime PI okay um okay
by the way sandal on our live stream
comments that we already have these
things like tagging rules tag set tag
box we've used tag for two other things
already you
I mean so the front end is also using
cell but that cell has very little to do
with a cell in a cell complex well
what's the name or or a cell in the
biology so we still used you know the
name cell for cells in the notebook so I
mean so be it I think that's the way
English language works um all right we
need at least another two hours with
these graph things to get it right
um and I mean with this this whole
collection of functionality there isn't
I mean I want you to sample some of it
but it's it's largely sort of higher
quality examples and the goal is to
refresh the notes because the original
notes yeah they were country they were
intended for a different purpose yeah
they were in appendix in a book and they
weren't necessarily quite terse um and
for no audience to kind of knew what
stare you can't really assume that
necessarily I think Ritter no I agree
asymptotic equivalent to know
asymptotically equal to
you
this is very weird
no it's not okay
I mean that's cool showing that is
really cool
but that's not right prime is also known
as prime number sequence I hardly think
so
yes it is it is no peaceable man
yeah P of n is your piece of n I know
but but that's a little different from
saying that is prime versus what prime
of n is is piece of that is that fashion
sequence the function the sequence that
we can't call a sequence because it's
very ill defined for non-integer
arguments all right what is this
progress reporting thing so that's so
for especially for time PI which say
keynote entities are more I understand
that but is that the same no no not a
chance
come on we've got two other ways to do
this we can't introduce the third one
here I'm happy for it to just say what
you want to call it and I thought it was
actually a plan to unified all those
interface still waiting for that okay
have you talked to Sushma about that
she's the one who's been dealing with
that I mean this is what is this thing
called in net train for example okay
we're not gonna have a difference okay
can we make sure okay this would have
come up I suppose when we get this
would've been a mess okay I gotta go
we need to continue this we really need
another two hours um there's a lot of
wonderful stuff here I look forward to
seeing it and we didn't even start in
geometry and graphics yet well no we're
going to do that right now that's the
meeting we're about to go to oh oh we
are okay yes oh oh we have only been an
hour
yes we've only been an hour here though
all right I will see you Roger at least
I chose of you in the unit in the
journal train graphics meeting are you
yes definitely
okay Charles could you please go
somewhere else so we don't have
background noise okay can you do that
Charles yeah I'm actually on mute so I'm
probably tried of course transform I'm
in the office that's school training
training progress reporting okay so so
that was a defensively name thing so
probably should be unified into progress
reporting so I guess we have to have a
meeting I I wish it didn't have to be
with me I guess it can include me to
talk about this progress the progress of
progress reporting and that will involve
Sushma and so on okay all right let's go
to our meeting about geometry and
graphics um and see you right there and
for people who live stream you are
encouraged to join us there see in a
moment